how to do more with less that's the
question that everyone in philanthropy
is struggling with and I think one key
part of doing more with less is to be
more strategic to realize what the
objectives you're truly trying to
accomplish are and then to drive with
greater focus towards those objectives
the other thing that is really critical
in doing more with less is to harness
the power of your partnerships the
people that you work with the
organizations that are committed to the
same objectives if they know that you're
in it together and you're working
towards the same objectives and you
agree on how to do more with less you
can actually have a greater impact so
those are two areas where strategic
philanthropy I think is is really trying
to work in a different way in this
downturn of their endowment charities
foundations that see themselves as
delivering care or filling a need that
is unmet in this economic downturn have
to take a different approach they have
to look at how to stretch those dollars
further and to get services that are are
in-kind services where they were in the
past using cash to provide those
services so in a lot of ways how we
approach this problem depends on whether
we're a strategic philanthropy or
whether we are focused on delivering the
charitable service that is greatly
needed in these economic downturns
over these last couple of years when
companies have had to dramatically
change their corporate giving I think
they have come to understand just how
dependent the communities in which they
thrive are on their philanthropy and I
think it has created a new engagement in
the community and an understanding that
they are part of making that community a
thriving place there are a lot of
companies Johnson & Johnson goldman
sachs many many others that have long
had a history of investing in the
communities that they live in and in
their employees and i think that out of
this economic downturn will come in
appreciation by corporations large and
small that that is part of their social
contract if you will with the rest of
the world